about this time every year gamespot
editors like to list our most
anticipated games for the coming year
2015's got a lot to look forward to but
we've got games to play gifts arap
whether to flee from so who even has
time for this anyways I do because I'm
paid to but your time is precious so
let's make this quick 15 games in four
minutes is about 16 seconds per game but
I've been talking for a while so it's
actually less sorry uncharted 4 you look
dope but I've already used up all your
time and I didn't even say your full
title next game no man's sky stole the
show at the vgx awards last year by
showing off the procedurally generated
gouts you full of worlds upon worlds
upon worlds that you can land on and
explore and then take off again to find
more new worlds it freaked everyone
right out if you're not freaked out
about it probably should be because you
can have your own world and who doesn't
want that yes please not many other new
ip's on this list but evolved is one of
them hot dang if we haven't done a lot
of cover done of all we like a vault
it's from the folks who made left for
dead we like left for dead involve you
can place a monster and terrorize your
friends we like terrorizing our friends
but in a videogame way not like speaking
of monsters how about that blood-borne
chock full of nasty monsters and nasty
weapons to kill him with call it dark
souls with shotguns follow the third
coming of the greatest action RPG of our
generation just don't call it delayed
past its march twenty fourth release
date speaking of delays the witcher 3
wild hunt is on this list but not until
later speaking of overused transitions
did you hear the one about the old one
eyed guy who hangs out in boxes with
women painted on the side kojima is an
odd duck but the man knows a little
something about stealth action games the
vaunted franchise heads into a big open
world in Metal Gear Solid 5 the phantom
pain and the hype is real speaking of 5s
persona 5 is coming out it's a persona
game and not like the fighting kind or
the dancing kind like the real super
duper great sync hours into it and make
it your new life you live here now kind
the kind that even though we know
basically nothing about it we still add
it to lists we do know a lot about
batman arkham knight and what we know is
that that man was basically made to be a
video game hero and the previous
Rocksteady Arkham games have been rad
look at this red to look at this rad car
don't ask why the car shoots bullets
just ask when you can shoot the car
bullets June second is the answer here's
a question does Ubisoft make games that
don't require you to climb towers and
scout the area I imagine you won't have
to do that in the division because UAVs
but who knows squad-based scavenging and
shooting sit in the shadow shell of a
sickly society sounds super sweet mala
lanna Ness Street how about a short
shout for Rainbow six siege
on the official list but ding chavez
taught me anything it's that sometimes
have to improvise so probably talk about
the witcher 3 now maybe not just yet you
don't mind waiting do you if you're a
star Wars fan you know a thing or two
about waiting but hey battlefront
Battlefront by way of battlefield no
less dice does combat and big open
spaces lots of vehicles real well that's
pretty much what we all want from
battlefront let's just hope they get
their servers up the stuff because it'll
be a hot day on Hoth before that game
gets delayed to miss the launch of the
movie did you ever see the tomb raider
movies pretty crap but that new tomb
raider game was excellent Raza the tomb
raider set to carry the torch forward to
the dank dark caves of x platform
exclusivity so if your console doesn't
start with an X you're gonna have to
wait a little longer to watch yourself
die horribly The Witcher 3 looks like it
has some pretty gross moths hey did you
know it's cool to own a wii-u now it's
got Mario and cart and smash and next
year it's gonna have Fox and like we
hope new starfox does first-person
cockpit view through the gamepad and 3rd
person view on the TV too many views no
such thing new Legend of Zelda is the
first ground up HD game in the series
and has a big open world with grass and
trees an opponent and octo rocks and
sword arrows to me Zelda tropes no such
thing all these Nintendo classics come
round to roost again but still no new
mega man game on the horizon or is their
mighty number 9 is a new mega man alike
by the original designer of the blue
bomber keiji inafune a made a mint on
Kickstarter and shape enough to be
pretty rockin and almost done with this
list and almost done with this year but
before the clock strikes midnight on
2014 one of these games will be in beta
and halo 5 Guardians new movement
abilities moving at 60 FPS might move
you to move on that xbox one year ago
five or so a tall tree and hope is all
we have that the witcher 3 won't get
delayed again because man if there's a
most of the most anticipated i think
this is it that gorgeous open-world
those gorgeous creatures that gorgeous
new protagonist and the gorgeous witcher
himself that we live in a time with such
marvelous anticipate ables is truly
through the grand and look at that we've
got a few seconds to spare any other
games you guys want to mention overwatch
captain cool it's over thanks for
watching
you